[Musique]
quand on parle de lutte au changement
climatique c'est le défi du 21e siècle
9 milliards de dollars c'est
l'investissement nécessaire pour que le
Québec puisse atteindre 60 % de ses
cibles de réduction de gaz à effet de
serre d'ici 2030 la troisième mouture du
Plan vert du gouvernement logo mise pour
y arriver sur l'électrification des
transports et la décarbonation des
industries Québec propose des incitatifs
les groupes environnementaux eux
auraient souhaité une approche plus
contraignante pourquoi avoir choisi la
carotte plutôt que le bâton je pose la
question ministre de l'Environnement et
des changements climatiques Benoît
Charette que je retrouve à Montréal je
charrette mon dimanche merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation merci de
l'invitation pourquoi donc davantage de
carottes que de bâtons
c'est les deux en fait on est venu
ajuster ajusté la réglementation donc ça
c'est la partie contrainte mais pour
aider les entreprises mais également les
citoyens on met en place une série de
mesures institutives donc c'est un bel
équilibre l'importance c'est le résultat
et vous l'avez mentionné ce sont des
budgets records je mets le gouvernement
du Québec n'a investi autant au niveau
de la lutte au changement climatique et
c'est surtout très encourageant parce
qu'on se rapproche de la teinte de notre
cible ce qui est aussi une très belle
nouvelle mais je reviens sur les
critiques des groupes environnementaux
le secteur industriel par exemple qui
est responsable du tiers des émissions
vous leur offrez des incitatifs plutôt
que d'imposer des mesures contraignantes
est-ce que d'être allé davantage avec de
la réglementation plus sévère sera pas
été plus efficace plus rapidement on
fait les deux la réglementation est
resserré donc des obligations pour les
entreprises cependant on les aide à nous
aider on a besoin en train de ces
diminutions là démission donc on les
aide à se conformer mais en même temps
faut pas perdre de vue l'importance que
ces entreprises là ont dans nos régions
ce sont des moteurs économiques
importants elles font face à une
compétition internationale dans des
marchés qui souvent n'ont pas les mêmes
restrictions que le Québec en matière de
lutte au changement climatique donc
c'est de bonnes lois et c'est même
nécessaire de les aider mais je le dis
tout le temps on les aide à nous aider
vous avez abordé les mesures parfois
plus l'axe dans d'autres juridictions
est-ce qu'il y a une crainte que si on
va trop loin ou si vous êtes trop dur il
y a des entreprises qui pourraient
simplement déserter le Québec c'est une
possibilité d'ailleurs le premier
ministre leur appeler au moment du
dévoilement du Plan on compose avec une
un marché économique fiscal qui est
nord-américain donc on ne peut pas ne
pas considérer les
réglementations qui sont quand je garde
dans d'autres juridictions donc oui on
est plus sévère bon les aide à se
conformer de sorte qu'elle puisse voir
un intérêt à maintenir leurs activités
en sol québécois et là c'est l'économie
du Québec naturellement qui est en
bénéficie les mesures que vous avez
identifié dans le plan que vous avez
présenté vendredi matin vous permettent
d'atteindre 60 % de la cible vixée d'ici
2030 pourquoi vous étiez pas capable
d'aller plus loin que 60%. et là aussi
c'est une excellente nouvelle c'est la
troisième mouture la première fois qu'on
présentait notre démarche on était à 42%
l'année dernière on était à 51% cette
année à 60% donc ce sont des
pourcentages qui s'additionnent années
après année et qui démontre qu'on va
dans la bonne direction et on se donne
rendez-vous printemps 2020 pour la
prochaine mise à jour et on aura fait
une autre progression sans doute très
intéressante
pour vous la quatrième mouture où la
prochaine mise à jour ça va vous nous
présenter quelque chose qui va au-delà
du 60% c'est ça oui en fait la
progression là 42 à 51 51 à 60 on a une
moyenne d'environ 9 points pourcentage
par année jusqu'à maintenant on ne
maintiendra pas cette cadence là
jusqu'en 2030 parce qu'on accéderait
largement la cible elle-même mais
surtout que d'année en année plus on se
rapproche du 100% plus les diminutions
d'émissions de GES sont difficiles donc
c'est pour ça que les premières années
là des bons de presque 10% on les prend
volontiers c'est bien certain mais dans
les dernières années faut pas se faire
d'illusion mais la progression
actuellement nous indique qu'on est sur
la bonne la bonne trajectoire pour être
à 100% en 2030 et je le dis souvent pour
le Québec ce sera une fleur pour la
planète c'est un petit peu plus triste
mais si on est à 100% et on y travaille
on sera vraisemblablement un des rares
États dans le monde à avoir atteint sa
cible de réduction de gaz à effet de un
mot sur le transport qui représente 43%
des émissions au Québec vous allez vous
misez sur l'électrification pour réduire
les émissions qu'est-ce que vous mesures
vont changer très exactement on a
maintenu le programme rouler vert pour
une année supplémentaire un programme
qui est très apprécié qui est très
sollicité donc pour chaque véhicule
électrique vendu l'acheteur ou
l'acheteuse Android subvention de 7000
dollars en notant qu'on respecte un
certain nombre de critères c'est de loin
la subvention à l'achat la plus
généreuse en Amérique du Nord mais on a
aussi des subventions pour que les les
consommateurs les entreprises puissent
installer des bornes de recharge donc
c'est des volets importants et
ultimement un changement réglementaire
qui lui est très contraignant n'ont pas
pour les consommateurs ou les
consommatrices mais pour les
constructeurs automobiles qui auront des
quotas des obligations de rendre
disponible
tu es là sur le marché québécois sans
quoi les constructeurs auront des
pénalités là excessivement élevée à
payer vous voulez que les Québécois
achète davantage de véhicules
électriques les véhicules sport
utilitaires les gros véhicules demeurent
très très prisé de la clientèle bon de
250 %, 90 et 2021 ça consomme 50% plus
d'électricité qu'une voiture vous êtes
aux gens faites fonctionner vos
lave-vaisselle de nuit vous leur dites
quoi pour qu'on pour les convaincre
d'acheter de plus petites voitures on
n'a pas voulu juger le choix des
consommateurs c'est quelque chose que
certains groupes nous demandaient de
pénaliser l'achat de vus en même temps
ce que on leur répond à ces gens c'est
que le Québec a un territoire
immensément vaste et ce n'est pas vrai
que l'on circule uniquement en milieu
très urbanisé on veut pas se mettre dans
le siège pour juger les gens je vois que
je vous ramène ça sur
un terrain plus personnel j'ai mon
gendre qui lui travaille dans la
construction il sait pas acheter trois
véhicules un pour lorsqu'il va
travailler l'autre pour lorsqu'il se
déplace à la avec la petite famille puis
l'autre lorsqu'il se déplace seul ce que
l'on veut encourager c'est
l'électrification l'électrification des
transports et lorsque c'est possible le
recours au transport collectif
d'ailleurs dans 9 milliards de dollars
on inclut pas les budgets pour le
transport collectif qui se situe à
hauteur de plusieurs dizaines de
milliards de dollars
ministre de l'Environnement des
changements climatiques merci d'avoir
été des nôtres un plaisir une belle fin
de journée beau de même